les clients sont de retour dans cet
hôtel 5 étoiles de bonnes
l'établissement a fait le plein depuis
le mois de juillet grâce aux touristes
français belges et hollandais une
reprise totale de l'activité mais les
craintes se tourner vers la rentrée très
peu de réservations pour cet automne
c'est rien ne change
la direction devra recourir de nouveau
au chômage partiel je peux mettre les
équipes en chômage partiel en début de
semaine ou en début de semaine et les
faire revenir en fin de semaine parce
que l'activité en a besoin
et puis le lundi quand y'a rien d'un jeu
une flexibilité qui doit permettre à
l'entreprise de maintenir ses 37 emplois
du côté du personnel des chambres du
restaurant ou du spa c'est le
soulagement
c'est très rassurant parce que c'est
vrai qu on va dire si on arrive bon
malgré qu'on fasse une bonne saison
c'est après la rentrée on n'a plus rien
c'est vrai que nous au niveau de nos
emplois ça peut être un petit peu on
peut se poser des questions alors que là
on sait que jusqu'au mois de décembre
voilà ça va vraiment aider tout le monde
un bol d'air également pour cette petite
entreprise d'événementiel
ça c'est ce genre d'opération envoyé
d'avant le château de savigny les beaune
enfin repas gaulois avec une broche mais
avec les crises du coc vide aucun
séminaire d'organiser depuis février la
société ne survivra jusqu'à la fin de
l'année que grâce aux aides de l'état
ainsi un contrat en janvier c'est pareil
c'est une société française implantée en
allemagne qui nous a bien spécifié noir
sur blanc que sur les contrats il
fallait que si jamais commis de repas
rond rembourser immédiatement sans frais
d'annulation qui fait qu'on aura
travaillé pour rien donc si on n'avait
pas cette aide de l'état et ce chômage
partiel
ça veut dire qu'on travaille pour la
gloire en bourgogne la saison
touristique doit durer jusqu'à la mi
novembre dans la région
le chômage partiel est ouvert à 29 mille
emplois du secteur